[Music]
did you hang out in the swamps while you
were there like the things I've always
wanted to go to the swamps when I'm down
in Louisiana I've never done it the
Bayou as we call it Oh as we locals
Bayou all the by all the bye y'all
it's yeah it's really cool you can take
these these fan boat tours or airboats
as they're called which is the yeah you
know the giant fan on the back and it's
run by a and it's just a skiff boat and
it skims across the surface you can go
over marshes and everything it's really
cool and really loud like insanely loud
right and one of the because it's an
airplane engine that powers this thing
right and you have to put on
noise-canceling ear muffs or whatever
and funny ear ear phones did say mop
yeah so let's go with my our mops ear
muffs yeah so yeah you you certainly are
a badass
the attendant you could you feed any of
the animals like you fed alligators what
alligators eat the alligators on airboat
tours eat marshmallows that something
makes them much less threat big to me
big scary alligators have a soft spot
for marshmallows Wow which I was
surprised by but also I kind of felt
like I wasn't on the most nature
environment Oh conscientious to her
right because we were flagrantly kind of
increasing the alligator diabetes
situation probably she's a terrible
problem yes